maybe this is the answer to this next
question if someone has never seen your
work before
um what is the first thing you'd like
them watching and why
well Paramount Studios Transformers rise
of the beasts
um no I'm I I don't know they're all
such a blur
um
um I I got I think I think I got lucky
with my first film that I ever did
living in Oblivion it was a comedy about
movie making made it in the mid 90s and
uh Steve Buscemi and Catherine Keener
and James legrow and germit Maroney and
there I was with this gang of like great
actors my first film uh in New York City
and I just thought
I just got really lucky and and Pierre
was pinching myself every day being
there I was shot for like five days
probably but it was a great film jumping
into why I get to talk to you uh when
they when you were offered this pitched
however you got involved was it like an
immediate yes
um was it one of these things because
this is something that your whole family
can watch and you know what I mean yeah
I mean I just like to mix it up and and
not repeat myself and I've never played
a a robot from a different galaxy uh who
has a bit of an evil streak running
through him
um I've done some other Voice work for
other things and I find it to be really
fun
um very unique from being on sets um
isolating at times but Stephen our
director was there on Zoom with me every
session he guided me through and he was
just he was so accessible and I I find
uh not relying on other things as an
actor and just solely your voice it
really can be very liberating and it
calls into Focus
how you important it is even when you're
on camera like what great actors like
Daniel Day-Lewis will do with their
voices every time how it's part
how it's just like a costume or or an
accent or something it's just how you
transform the voice transform is uh just
as important as anything else
um and my favorite actors have always
done that did you enjoy recording the
efforts or do you find that to be
tedious it's very weird if taken out of
context
um if you're in the room going
um if somebody's in the next apartment
um they will have you have questions
um
but no it's all fun and it's you know I
mean you get to
wear your own clothes and your
comfortable shoes and not have hair and
makeup
you know uh you're in an air-conditioned
sound booth it's great
um and the people over at soundtracks is
a place in the Flatiron that I work at a
lot it's I'm very familiar with all of
them and they just they they're super
sweet over there he's one of the things
that's cool about Transformers is that
you there's a lot of toys made a lot of
merch uh yeah are you looking got some
in the mail the other day I was gonna
ask you what are you looking forward to
actually owning and do you feel or do
you have a sense of ownership I don't
know my son owns it all now it's it's uh
I was saying earlier I didn't want to
wait for his birthday because I would be
re-gifting from Paramount I would feel
cheap about wrapping up a present from
Paramount
um so I just gave it to him right away
and it was he came home from school and
it was like
what Transformers this uh it was pretty
fun that's great uh I'm a lot of the
stuff I can't give my kids because it's
like it's like I don't know dangerous
it's like it's spiky things from weird
movies that I've done that just aren't
kid friend friendly you know you can
hurt yourself with them but the choice
yeah
hello uh I'm really looking forward to
brothers because I'm a fan of Max and
with Palm Springs I don't know anything
about this movie yeah so I'm curious is
it a palm spring situation where there's
like some big twists that I do not I
won't see coming or is it one of these
you're just trying to keep everything
under wraps I like keeping everything
under wraps because it's just fun to
nobody knew what a C-3PO was when I was
a kid until you saw him in the theaters
and it's like whoa now you know
everybody knows so much about a movie
before we see it
um uh so not that this movie is Star
Wars me and Brolin Josh Brolin play
brothers and the the origin of this of
how we made this movie is we pitched it
to Studios because a friend of his said
you and Dinklage both have really big
heads you guys should play brothers and
I was like and he called me up and he's
like my friend said this you want to
play I was like yeah that's uh movies
have been made for um for Less ideas
than that this is perfect
um and I was a huge fan of Josh's work
so we play Brothers okay I won't
approach any more than that but that's
awesome it's a comedy uh there we go
yeah I um my last thing for you it's
very funny sir the second you want to
show it to me I will be in the screening
room watching and there's a talking
robot in the end too who uh
yeah no it's discouraged
don't tell Paramount Great last thing
for you I'm a big fan of Francis
Lawrence I know you're in the new Hunger
Games movie yeah I'm a big fan of
Francis as well having just worked with
him yeah and I'm just curious can you
talk a little bit about uh your
character do you get to wear cool
costumes what it was like working with
Francis
um yeah it was great we were in Berlin
last fall Berlin is such a beautiful
city
um uh Francis is so great he's so kind
and patient and great with actors
um and knows exactly
how he sees the film which you always
want in a director uh he sort of sees it
so clearly any and he relays that to you
as an actor so so well
um
I ca I'm you know I think the preview is
online uh so it's sort of you can kind
of see that maybe I'm not the happiest
camper in the film and uh uh Viola
announces me as the creator of The
Hunger Games which is what I am
which is sort of like careful what you
create uh because it can because of the
later films that gets out of hand
um when you try to create something
that's helpful uh yeah watch out because
it can uh
copsy-turvy on that note I need to stop
I'm just gonna say sir it is great to
talk with you I wish you nothing but the
best